versus ah no it's it's pretty difficult
to answer because when we developed
fighting games we try to keep the core
community in mind and also the general
audience who like to play these games
but currently the situation is with
fighting games you have Street Fighter 5
just released a lot of people are
playing that fervently we have a large
crowd out there that are waiting for
Tekken 7 so we don't want to split these
communities so the window that's a good
window to release technique across
Street Fighter is something that's
become much more difficult recently so
it's kind of on hold for the moment I
guess you could say it'll take inside of
the aerodrome I looked at it
muscle jockey although that's a
difficult question because at first
glance a fighting game looks like it
might be something that would work well
for you to play as you mentioned we had
the Tekken revolution and because the
fighting games started the arcade where
you pay as you go you know 100 yen or
$1.00 per play we tried that online
virtual and it's it's kind of tough but
then if you make the game totally free
to play it's kind of hard to get enough
revenue to support the game so it was
quite difficult honestly for Tekken 7
Harada would rather have a package you
know your traditional way of selling the
game so that we could include all of the
elements that we want without changing
the game design touch to match that
model but just to provide that a tech
and everyone expects let's go
awesome deal Amano well this well
check-ins haven't started in obviously
arcade which is very hard to you know
pull out the land cable or something
like that you know and Tekken 7 is
actually the first fighting game in
arcades it does networking battles now
but we don't have that problem to date
because the user themselves can shut off
the land so but when we make the jump to
console where we haven't really
mentioned our plans regarding
ragequitting
so far but we can say that in the past
you know obviously we are keeping our
eyes on what other titles are doing and
what the users respect are I mean what
kind of expectations they have regarding
that but in the past Tekken is also kind
of displayed a player's what do you call
it a disconnect rate before you decide
to fight them and then the chooser could
decide not to fight that person if the
disconnect rate was pretty high so we
have done some things like that in the
past already and we're still thinking
about what to do this time let's get
there so silicosis do this or are they
almost in it mom was in the video go see
personally in urado was a saying that
back when he used to play Ultima Online
when someone would do something bad like
you know be very vulgar or rude to
someone they would get thrown in a
virtual Jail where their character was
on display and they were muted but
people could say whatever they wanted to
to those people for a few hours and the
person had to endure that if they wanted
to continue playing outside of that so
they have something similar for Tekken
would be kind of interesting if you had
a rage quitter in a virtual jail and
they have to fight another rage quitter
and until they win they can't escape
and their main character would be locked
on the main character select screen hit
II would be kind of a fun way to address
that
holiday must intervene huzzah tomorrow
edik autism until no mana what can I get
over the evidence there is one I forget
the hanker in the UK oh no son was with
us it was I think the media was from the
UK I'm not sure but they were your your
casual audience that didn't know a whole
lot about gaming and they just happen to
be at event so when they came in they
said oh hello mr. Onan - Parata and the
opposite for Oh No so they both looked
at each other they got ah let's do this
and they they'd be their other
counterpart and so Harada went on about
the Street Fighter series and history
and legacy and all those on the same for
Tekken and the whole time the press had
no idea and but I'm sure that the the
viewers told them that when they
actually heard it because it's actual TV
crew so Kappa Gamma got him the
container costume oh don't worry
father's only economical solutions you
could talk about that well back in the
day he was in Shinjuku which is actually
the location that if you know Sega's
game Yakuza that's where you kind of go
around there and yeah so his arcade was
in that that area so there was a lot of
Yakuza back in the day it would come in
and ask for protection money and as a
company we don't pay that so it was
always a case that he would send them
away it was usually the chimp era which
is kind of in a very low level yeah cuz
a-you know Punk's per se but one day you
had these three guys in suits that look
like the real deal and Harada was he was
quite young at the time and he got kind
of scared and went to the back office
and got the manager and the manager says
okay hirato go go in the back and hide
for 10 minutes I'll take care of it
there's these three guys in suits they
look like high level you know Authority
members of the Yakuza and then so the
manager comes back later and he does
a'right are you fool what are you doing
that was actually one of our company
employees and so he's very famous our
company but the the guy in charge of I
think you would say regional sales at
time for the arcade division it was
actually him and some of our company
people but he looked exactly like the
real thing and in Herat I have scared
you